The whole world is watching the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier
continue their fight against the Flag-Smashers,
as the increasingly-unhinged John Walker
continues to tarnish Captain America's shield.
Here's some of the easter eggs you may have missed
in The Falcon and the Winter Soldier episode four.
In the first act of "The Whole World is Watching,"
Sam, Bucky, and Zemo try to get information
on Donya Madani, Karli's deceased adoptive
mother. It's a dead-end for Sam and Bucky,
as the duo seem to scare off everyone they
come in contact with. Sam does manage to
have one brief conversation with a refugee, but
he refuses to give up any information on Donya.
Then we see Zemo outside, approaching a group
of children while singing "Baa Baa Black Sheep."
He dumps a pile of candy in front of them —
the same Turkish delight he mentioned to Bucky
and Sam, inside the Latvian apartment. He tells
the group of kids that the candy was his son's
favorite. Zemo uses the sweets as a way to dazzle
the youngsters and get information out of them.
It works like a charm: The little girl reveals
when and where Donya's funeral will be.
While this seems like the sort of simple, clever
tactic you might see on an episode of Law & Order,
Zemo's use of the candy actually has a
connection to another fictional universe.
"Turkish delight."
Turkish delight is the candy the
White Witch uses in The Chronicles
of Narnia to get information out of Edmund
Pevensie. It's Edmund's favorite candy,
but the White Witch's sweets are also
enchanted, making them impossible to resist.
In "The Whole World is Watching," we
finally get to see the Winter Soldier
in all his blade-wielding glory.
During the high-octane fight with
the Flag Smashers at their home
base, Bucky shows off his skills,
notably his ability to throw and catch a
knife by its handle like it's no big deal.
The move is a nod to Captain America: The
Winter Soldier, with Bucky replicating a
move he used on Steve Rogers during the
street fight scene in the 2014 movie.
In "The Whole World is Watching," Bucky's
knife does a couple more spins than it does
in the film. Both scenes, however, show
off just how slick Bucky's skills are.
"What's with all the knives?"
This display of skill is yet another instance of
the series referencing the MCU's most memorable
moments. It should also be noted that this moment
shows Bucky's growth as a character, as he is not
willing to kill, which is why he throws the knife
next to his opponent's head, and not through it.
Back when we first met him in The Winter Soldier,
in contrast, he had no problem with ending a life.
In "The Whole World is Watching," Walker kills a
Flag Smasher by driving his shield into his chest.
This gives us one of the series' most
eerie shots: John Walker seen from below,
as he holds a bloody shield. This specifically
invokes a prior moment in Steve Rogers' history,
making it all the more clear how dramatically
the old Cap differs from the new Cap.
In Captain America: Civil War's final
battle, Steve uses his shield to smash
Iron Man's helmet. Instead of landing a
blow to the head, as the audience expects,
Cap digs his shield into Tony's arc reactor,
which puts his suit out of commission. Steve
easily could have killed or seriously injured
Tony in that moment, but that's not who he is.
He uses his shield as a way to subdue
his opponent, instead of killing him.
The Falcon and the Winter Soldier
employs cinematography reminiscent
of what's used in that Civil War scene,
making for a unique and potent callback.
Walker doesn't have a personal history with
this Flag Smasher, as Steve does with Tony,
but he also doesn't have the ability to
stop himself and assess the situation,
which makes him highly dangerous.
There's a darkness inside of Walker, which
has been emphasized by the Super-Soldier
serum running through his veins. Steve
doesn't have that darkness in him,
making him a much better
Captain America on all fronts.
"That shield doesn't belong to you."
"You don't deserve it!"
Check out one of our newest videos
right here! Plus, even more Looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.